my greatest concern today is that we
continue in the myth that violence works
and the myth that militarism and war and
occupations actually solve any problems
in the myth that we need weapons in our
world today and then the myth that we
need armies when we see that these
things are no use to us they're part of
the problem so today in situation in so
many countries governments are using
militarism force they're abusing
people's human rights they're ignoring
international law and selling it aside
my concern is that we as a human family
have a tremendous legacy of
international law 3ds human rights and
the United Nations the United Nations is
our mother in the sense for the world
and we are in danger of destroying our
world with this mindset of militarism
it's a very cruel it's very cruel to
take a young man and woman and teach the
market killed another man and woman
that's a very cruel thing to do and we
do it every government doesn't and it's
just something we have to change our
mindsets from militarism and killing 21
of non-violence and love and solving our
problems through international law and
human rights and upholding the United
Nations reforming it yes but uphold at
the United Nations we can solve our
problems together through em the united
nations international rights human
rights every country every person is
equal there should be no super parse
they belong to Los answering at this
center